Marty one of the wonderful things about
this movie is its sense of anarchistic
dark comedy which reminds me so much of
your earlier films like after hours in
King of Comedy I didn't think I could
bring myself around to dealing with that
world again in terms of in Anupa we'll
put it this way in a new structure or
new style or a silent was extending the
old style how would I extend that how
are we projected forward you see how
would we make it something that would be
special and different from the other
styles of styles that were developed in
Goodfellas and Casino for example the
style in Goodfellas and Casino is one
thing the black comedy of the dark
comedy of after-hours and King of Comedy
is another maybe they blend the two you
know this project has been something
you've been working on since 2007 that
was the ability to really push the
envelope with this and not censor look I
was fascinated with doing something like
a modern-day Caligula you know the the
darker nature of these guys not
necessarily on Wall Street because the
more I researched this it wasn't
necessarily about Wall Street it was
about something that's in our very
culture you know the attitude of these
guys they the need to incessantly
consume as much as possible with
complete disregard for anyone except you
know themselves you know doing a film
with a with a lead character like this
is who is so dismissive to everyone and
everything I mean I mean there's some
key moments in this film that Jonah
keeps talking about where he goes well
you know she blew every but everybody in
the office anyway he killed himself
which was Stratton's for a suicide so
anyway and then you move on with the
picture it's just like this there's the
these characters that just keep pushing
forward and we don't see the wake of
their destruction they just keep pushing
forward and and to get a film of that
nature financed I think at any timeframe
but especially now is incredibly
difficult we we did we did get it
financed
um you know at about five or six years
ago but it fell apart and there was some
struggles with it and it wasn't really
until you know our collaborators and
financers at red granite came and said
look we want we feel like there's a
marketplace for films like this and we
want you guys have complete you know
artistic freedom to to push the
boundaries with it because that's what's
going to make it interesting it really
is being honest in the material and we
made a number of films over the years
friends might here sitting here know
that we had to fight for the material in
areas that we shouldn't have had to I
think and so you know it's you try to be
honest with it matter I guess it's not
for everyone you know it's something
that may not agree but everyone may not
agree with but you have to be as
straightforward to the material as
possible and as few restrictions as
possible I've never been in an
environment where you felt safer and had
a barrier around you to be as honest and
reckless at the same time and that was a
something that I hope from now on I get
to be around as much as possible and
that was a beautiful thing to get to
walk into honestly my indication from
from Marty that the scene was going well
is when I could hear him laughing from
behind the monitors so we'd be
improvising and I'd be thinking in my
head I'm probably sound like an idiot
right now I must be saying something
really stupid and then I'd hear Marty
laugh and then I'm like oh no I'm on the
right track it's good if I would keep
going down that that down that road
until I hear laughing staufen the
nothing okay change tact a little bit no
we we sat down and spoke about it a
little bit to begin with particularly
the the more racier scenes so that were
both on the same page about where we're
going to and funnily enough I I was the
one I thought I walked into the meeting
thinking that I was going to have to
really fight to keep my clothes on and
by the end of it I was like no I think
she wouldn't no she wouldn't do that she
wouldn't where she wouldnt be having
underwear on then it wouldn't you won't
do that
she just wouldn't that doesn't make
sense so actually I was the one fighting
- yeah well it was a matter - of saying
really I said I just need the freedom to
be able to do what I want doesn't mean
we're going to use it exactly doesn't
mean we're going to use it yeah yeah
well if you're going to trust any
director with those sort of things it's
going to be body so and you did mention
King of Comedy and I keep referencing
this because I remember seeing a
documentary on King of Comedy or footage
from King of Comedy where a lot of the
actors would get together and take the
material and improvise around around the
scene and then on the day we dream
provides that and that was the feel of
this it was a constant you know there's
not not many directors that will you
know stay with actors and try to get
something from their characterization of
these of these people even if it's not
essential to the structure of the plot
and that's what's so great about what
Marty does and his and his process if he
feels like you know ultimately that the
characters become the plot and if he
feels like something's going to happen
there even if it's not essential to the
building blocks of getting to the ending
he'll stick with it all day long and I
remember asking about Goodfellas over
and over again and how he got that
famous scene with Joe Pesci saying what
am i clown what am I here to abuse ed
that wasn't even in the script the guys
just got together and they all started
talking and but that was the feel of
this movie as well you know we didn't
have we weren't beholden to you know a
specific plot structure was the
characterization of these people but
those speeches yes that was something
that I had been thinking around about
for six years there were some of the
most brilliantly written speeches I'd
ever read there were these greed fuel
you know brave heart cries to battle but
he was influencing everybody to go screw
as many people over as possible and
there was a huge build-up for those
those scenes and I'd thought about them
for such a long period of time that the
day I actually arrived on set I had
strep throat and couldn't do any of them
class so we had to wait I actually had
the real Jordan come into CAA
and I filled the room up with a bunch of
assistants and I asked him to recreate
one of those features for me so I got to
see it play out so it's really inspired
by the real guy I mean I got to see him
stand in front of a roomful of people
it's really filled with trepidation at
first he took about a minute or two to
warm up once he got going he is really
one of the most gifted public speakers
I've ever seen and just started ripping
and I was praying that my digital
recorder was working and got some of it
on tape and wrote a lot of things down I
just observed him and then recreated
that some of his own words mine included
and just sort of shaped that whole those
whole speeches together and you know of
course you read it back to yourself as
you're writing it and I thought I was
doing a pretty good impression of Leo in
my own head he's so much better at being
Leonardo DiCaprio than I am and when you
see it I was like oh my god you know it
just goes to such a new level and it was
just just incredible to watch Leo you
also met Jordan Belfort did that
influence your performance at all very
much so yes very I spent many months
with him and what was so refreshing
about him was the fact that look he knew
he made a lot of mistakes this was a
very dark period in his life so he was
incredibly candid and an always
forthright and always honest a lot of
times we'd be talking about specific
scenes say and he would say it's lit it
was like that but actually was 10 times
worse and I'm going to tell you why and
I really had a worse intention I really
wanted to screw that guy over so you
know I all that insight and especially a
lot of the sales stuff I mean he took me
through beat by beat the lowering of the
boys you know how you manipulate
somebody it's all part of you know the
way we depict him at the end of this
movie is is what he's he's doing right
now his might life is much different now
but and he and he's um you know trying
to make amends of the past and repair
what he did but it was amazing to work
with somebody and be able to literally
call somebody sometimes in between takes
and say I have a question no you just
don't get that Allen you've been working
with Marty since 1989 with some very
large ensemble cast this you told me has
a hundred and ten
different speaking parts in it I mean
Goodfellas was a huge cast and casino
was a huge cast really huge and gangs of
New York had a huge cast so this wasn't
quite as scary in the same way as as
those were but this was a really large
cast and I would say that probably the
biggest challenge was making sure that
we got each of the brokerage firms and
the groups kind of within you know the
young people after the Forbes article
comes out we needed like the young
hungry people who were coming in and
then that first you know Matthew
McConaughey where he is and having that
upper crust feeling for that group of
brokers and then of course in the garage
and you know they all were very specific
faces and types and so you know we
really work at and making sure that
we're getting each feeling right
yes well Marty wanted it to be ferocious
the movie and have an incredible thrust
to it but then when we started getting
these wonderful comic scenes you know it
seemed like with Matthew McConaughey and
Leo I mean how can you not let that
scene run it's so beautifully written by
Terry and so beautifully acted and so it
was a little odd that we would you know
be tearing straight ahead and then
screech to a stop for five minutes and
but that was the way that it was unique
to this movie don't you think that's
what we're trying once we saw that
happens let's keep going that way let's
see how far we could go to a break to
break those rhythms and not not have a
traditional continuity in a sense or a
traditional narrative as much as
possible because plot is not what this
film is about Marty hates plot anyway I
like another movie might be the biggest
challenge actually was having hundreds
of men in suits and shirts and ties and
and and sort of somehow trying to make a
trying to sort of create differences in
their characters when basically they're
all wearing the same thing and
a lot of that comes down to the ties
actually and it's saying it's it's the
ties and how the ties change through the
periods from the 80s where they're
really garish and then through the early
90s they say bit like the 80s and then
they get more Conservatives we go long I
arrive with a bunch of clothes and we
try them all on we go through loads of
different kinds of shirts those are
different kinds of pants and and the
glasses and everything and after a while
the character develops a carrot comes
out of that we you put something on you
put the the high-waisted baggy jeans
well the really horrible socks and the
shoes and the shirt and then suddenly
someone goes this is it this is the
character this is this is this is where
it's going to go and is going to have
all those really nasty colors all mashed
up together and trying to look waspy and
try yeah yeah and it was yeah it was
that yeah with it with the sweater over
the shoulder thing they are the pastel
colored sweaters yeah I wore some
Sandy's old clothes yeah yeah yeah
actually actually yeah what were they
which outfits which I mean could you go
ha ha ha ha no I did actually go into my
loft and drag up my old eighties and
nineties clothes hi Saturday yeah see
she wears the blue know the dress that
I'm wearing when we're in on the boat in
Italy yeah yeah and them it says Sicily
right here yeah yeah yeah believable the
mighty gave the tickets Iruka and
actually I've got an embarrassing
confession one of the one of the yes
frost Ichi no tell them tell them the
scene of the girl with Lia and the
candle let's go yes Venice was your name
yeah that was my outfit yeah are you
serious
was it really I still fence Wow
that is fantastic